Selena Gomez raps season three of only
murders in the building
could this honestly get any better the
quick answer yes cell shares this pick
with guest star Meryl Streep in honor of
completing filming calling the season
deliriously hilarious challenging and an
absolute dream
sorry it's me
isn't it yep Merrell's definitely got a
lot to do with it it's fantastic in the
caption Selena can't help but fan girl
over the iconic actress or as she calls
her the woman I adore look up to and
love this is I think the most beautiful
gift
certainly have great guest stars I would
like to think people are lining up the
only murderous cast revealed Mira was
joining the show back in January along
with Paul Rudd the gang is back oh wait
well I do think it could get a little
bit better why what do you mean
Steve
yeah oh please thank you thank you ma'am
uh just the tea that I had asked for a
half an hour ago I'm okay thank you for
your sweep
oh Selena Gomez had us all losing our
minds when first of all she reveals you
and then Meryl Streep yeah
I agree I don't know it's the most it's
the most amazing thing to be and to be
in that room you know Selena is great
and I've worked with Selena and she's a
really good friend of my uh adore her
Martin Short and Steve Martin are Mount
Rushmore
Andrea Martin was in that room and for
any comedy fan or uh I mean she's
she is such like a home run hitter I
can't believe that I'm in the room with
Andrea Martin and then you pan over and
it's Meryl Streep so uh yeah a bit of a
a bit of a Powerhouse but looks like
Paul who met a cameo in the season 2
finale is faring just fine with his new
Powerhouse co-star
[Music]
now Selena's post with mural isn't the
only thing the star is sharing fans
might remember cell donning all white in
these snaps on social media while it's
unclear why her character Mabel's
wearing a wedding gown safe to say
there's lots in store as the trio Dives
in for another season is this really
happening again well you know who are we
without a homicide
yeah Shall We Begin
[Music]
foreign